[Alkış]
hanımefendiler beyefendiler Merhaba ben
Kamil kaplan bir opera sanatçısıyım
Bununla birlikte oldukça tutkulu bir
hayalperest olarak tanımlıyorum kendimi
burada Bu etkinlikte konuşmacı olmak
için ilk davet aldığımda hiç düşünmeden
hemen kabul ettim
hayatımın kırılma noktalarından bir
tanesi olduğuna inanıyorum
burada konuşmak acaba haddim mi diye hiç
düşünmeden kendimi sorgulamadan hemen
kabul ettim o an hayatımın kırılma
noktalarından yalnızca bir tanesiydi
kırılma noktalarının
bazen zamanın içinde fark edildiğini
olayın
yaşanırken fark edildiğini çoğu zamansa
olaydan durumdan çok zaman geçtikten
sonra fark ettiğimizi düşünüyorum
vardığımız noktadan baktığımızda kırılma
noktalarımızı farklı biçimlerde
yorumlayabildiğimize inanıyorum
ve bugün bizi burada buluşturanın
hepimizin ayrı ayrı kırılma noktaları
olduğuna inanıyorum
bu etkinlik benim hayatımda ilk defa
deneyimlediğim
bir durum ve şu anda burada olmaktan
dolayı çok büyük mutluluk duyuyorum
ve hepimizi burada buluşturan hepimizin
ayrı ayrı kırılma noktalarına gerçekten
gönülden teşekkür ediyorum Hepsine
minnettarım
hoş geldiniz
size kendi Hayat yolculuğundan bazı
Hatıralar anlatacağım Heyecanımı da
lütfen maruz görün
küçük bir çocukken
ekmek tahtasını ya da bir süpürge sapını
Gitar gibi tutarak
kendimi kocaman ağzına kadar dolu bir
stadyumda şarkı söylerken Hayal ederdim
dans etmeyi şarkı söylemeyi çok severdim
ama bunları çoğu kez kendi kendime
yapardım zaman zaman
arkadaşlarımda şahit olmuşlardır bu
duruma Hatta
bir gün sabahın köründe bağıra çağıra
şarkı söylerken kafama bir çakmak
yemişliğim de var
tebessümle andığımız güzel bir hatıraydı
Bu benim için
ortaokul yıllarında
müzik ile müzik eğitimi ile ilişkim
yalnızca okuldaki müzik derslerimizde
blok flüt çaldığımız müziğin dilini
solfeji öğrenmeye çalıştığımız
haftada bir ya da 2 saat olan o dersler
pek ilişkim o kadardı
Müzik öğretmenimiz
bir
koro kurmak için bir ortaokul Korusu
kurmak için seçme yapacaktı
sınıfta hepimize
toplu halde bir türkü söyletti
tek tek hepimizin kulağına hepimizin
sesine
eğerek dinledi
türkü bittiğinde omuzuna dokunduğum
kişileri seçtim dedi benim dokunmamıştı
beni seçmedi
hangi türküyü söylediğimizi Gerçekten
hatırlamıyorum ama öğretmenimin beni
koroya seçmediğini çok iyi hatırlıyorum
bu duruma
hiç üzülmedim bir üzüldüğümü
anımsamıyorum
öğretmenime de asla kızgın değilim
fakat ortaokuldayken öğretmenin beni ya
oraya seçseydi ne olacaktı o zaman
hayatın Belki biraz daha farklı olacaktı
ortaokuldayken müzik dersleri ile
müzikle olan iletişim artacağı için
belki de liseye gideceğim zaman güzel
sanatlar lisesine gitmeyi tercih
edecektim öyle bir kapı aranacaktı
açılacaktı bana Fakat öyle olmadı
ortaokul boyunca ilişkin yalnızca müzik
derslerinde ibadet kaldı
ortaokul biterken Mayıs ayında babamı
kaybettim
mezun olmama yalnızca birkaç aylık bir
süre vardı
o dönem için kendimi şöyle tanımlıyorum
bir çocuk olarak uyudum
sabah uyandığımda sabah uyandığımda ise
artık bir yetişkindim
Oysa ki öyle değildi
Ama öyle zannetmiştim öyle bir his
yaşadığını anlamıyorum bu günden
Biz üç kardeşiz en büyük olan benim abi
olmanın da vermiş olduğu yetkiyle
kendimi Evin erkeği gibi hissetmeye
başlamıştım
az önce de dediğin gibi buna hiç gerek
yoktu annemiz bize hem annelik hem
babalık yapabilmek için oldukça gayret
gösterdi her iki makamı da bize eksiksiz
hissettirebilmek için elinden geleni
çabaladı her şeyi yaptı Ona minnettarım
huzurunuzda ona çok teşekkür ediyorum
yaşadığımız bu kaybın ardından
14 yaşındayken
şöyle bir düşünce oluştu
hemen bir meslek sahibi olmalıyım ve
para kazanmalıyım
bunun için en kısa yol Meslek Lisesine
gitmekte
Bursa Demirtaşpaşa endüstri meslek
lisesi elektrik bölümüne kaydımı
yaptırdım
ilk yılında
genel not ortalamasının nispeten biraz
üzerinde olduğu için notlarım Benim
teknik liseye geç yaptılar lise oldu
benim için 4 yıl
Oysa ki eğitim öğretim hayatın boyunca
notlarım hiçbir zaman çok parlak olmadı
çok çalışkan bir öğrenci olmadım
ne yazık ki çok fazla ilgimi çekemedi
okuldaki dersler
lise 1 sınıfın
yıl sonunda yıl sonlarında yapılan
etkinlikleri organizasyonları Hepiniz
çok iyi bilirsiniz eğlenceleri bir
orkestra sahne almıştı
onları hayranlıkla izlemiştim yaptıkları
şeyin bir sihir olduğuna İnanıyordum
hangi şarkıları çaldılar yine
hatırlamıyorum ama onlara çok özendiğimi
çok iyi hatırlıyorum
lise ikinci sınıfta
Bir gün okuldan eve otobüsle dönerken
bir arkadaşıma rastladım otobüsle Aynı
mahallede Oturduğumuz bir arkadaşımdı
Onun bir gitarı olduğunu
idrarını satmak istediğini birkaç gün
evvelinde öğrenmiştim
otobüste el sıkıştık anlaştık artık
bizim bir gitarımız vardı
fakat bir gitar öğretmenimiz yoktu
o dönemlerde özel ders öğretmenlerine
kursiyelerine ulaşmak günümüzdeki kadar
belki de kolay değildi erişmek Kolay
değildi Bizim de maddi durumumuz Bunun
için çok öyle bir şey değildi gitarımız
vardı öğretmenimiz yoktu ama
öğrenmeliydik
bir yol belirlemeliydim
gitar çalmayı bilen müziği bilen
arkadaşlarıma sordum Bu nasıl oluyor bu
Nasıl oluyor izledim onları nasıl
yapıyorlar neler yapıyorlar kitapları
açtım baktım Bu nasıl olabilir denedim
yanıldım denedim yanıldım sonunda gitar
çalıp şarkı söylemeye başlamıştım
3 ay kadar sonra
okulunda Küçük çaplı bir dinleti bile
yaptım
bundan 6 ay kadar sonra ise
kafelerde
gitar çalıp şarkı söylemeye sahne almaya
başlamıştım ve hatta para kazanmaya
henüz 16 yaşındaydım
öncesinde olduğu gibi Lisede de
yine okulun dersleri çok fazla ilgimi
çekmiyordu genellikle elimde gitarım her
gün yeni bir şeyler yeni şarkılar
öğrenmeye çalıştığım çabaladım gayret
gösterdiğim bir dönemdi
hem okuyordum Hem cumartesi günleri
müzik yapıyordum Çok amatörce ama
lezzetini hissini tadını hiç unutmadığın
büyük
keyifle yapıyordun müziği okuldan
arkadaşlarım
mahalleden arkadaşlarım öğretmenlerim
Hatta oturduğumuz apartmandaki
komşularımız bile bir sürü
Programıma geldiler destek oldular
dinlediler mutlu ettiler beni motive
ettiler
sonunda
ilgimi çeken bir şey bulmuştum
müzik yapmak
ilgimi çekmeyen okuldaki derslerime özel
göstermiyorum ama gitara gitarıma onu
seviyordum okşuyordum
şarkılara daha başka yaklaşıyordum
ilgimi çeken şeyi bulmuştum
ve kendimi geliştirmek için çok çaba
sarf ettim
lise son sınıfa geldiğimizde
atölye öğretmenimiz bize bir proje ödev
verdi bu odayı ödev 1 yıllık kapsayan
bir ödevdi Bir yılın sonunda alacağımız
not; koca bir yılda etkileyecekti
Ben dedim ya ilgim yok o yüzden
projeyi olması gerektiği gibi
sonuçlandıramadım ne yazık diye
öğretmenin beni yanına çağırdı gittim
yanına
projelerde yok
adamın karşısına rakamla sıfır yazdı
bana gitarın yanında mı diye sordu Evet
yanında Tabii ki yanımda e Getir bakalım
dedi koştum gitarımı kattığım gibi
öğretmenimin yanındaydım
birkaç şarkı istedi ona çaldım
sonra birkaç şarkı daha istedi O
şarkıları bilmiyordum
çalamadım
o şartları Öğretmenim bana ödev verdi
birkaç gün sonra onun yanına gittim O
şarkıları kendisine çaldım
sıfırın yanına kocaman bir on ekledi
bana Tam 100 puan verdi
Sen zaten gitarcı olacaksın elektrikçi
olmayacaksın Aferin sana dedi sırtımı
fazladır sağ olsun
lise bitecekti
ilk yılda izlediğim çok etkilendiğim çok
özendiğim o orkestra gibi Tıpkı orkestra
gibi yıl sonu şenliklerinde
Biz de birkaç arkadaş bir araya gelip
bir orkestra kurarak bir konser
vermiştik ilk yılında özendiğim
durumun içinde bulmuştum kendimi
hayatımın en keyifli en mutlu
günlerinden bir tanesiydi
ardından sınavsız geçişle Uludağ
Üniversitesi Teknik Bilimler Meslek
Yüksekokulu elektrik bölümüne
sınavsız geçiş yaptım
o dönemde haftada 6 gece Bursa'da bir
barda sahnem alıyordum Eve Dönüş saatin
oldukça geç oluyordu
ilgimi çekmeyen bir yere ilgimi çekmeyen
derslere
sabah 2 saatlik mesafedeki okula gitmek
çok zor geliyordu benim için
ve Devamsızlıktan kaldım
o dönemde oldukça Yalın yoğun
çalışıyordum
barlarda sahne alıyordum
paramı kazanıyordum hayatımı
kazanıyordum ama hayatımın sonrası için
bir karar vermeliydim
hayatımda müzik olsun istiyordum o zaman
bununla ilgili ciddi bir eğitimi
almalıyım Lisans eğitimim Bununla ilgili
olmalı diye düşündüm ve eğitim
fakültelerinin müzik öğretmenliği
bölümlerine hazırlanmaya karar verdim
ilk yılında
bir şehirleri ne kadar az bilirsek ne
kadar bilmezsek
o kadar çok bildiğimizi zannedebiliyoruz
ne bu hayatta öyle bir yanılgıya
düşebiliyoruz
Ben aldığım yüksek alkışların
Belki de bana verdiği gazla
benim için kolay bir sınav olacağını
düşünmüştüm fakat öyle olmadı İlk
yılında yalnızca Uludağ Üniversitesi'nde
sınava girdim müzik öğretmenliği
bölümüydü ve kazanamadım
bir çoktu ama bununla birlikte yılmadım
da önümüzdeki yıl tekrar denerim
o yıl bir arkadaşım Konya Selçuk
Üniversitesi'nde Opera bölümünü kazandı
Devlet konservatuarında
bu haberi aldığında
Opera sanatıyla ilgili ilk defa bir
fikrim olmuştu ilk defa duymuştum
Genel manada toplumumuzdan ne yazık ki
uzak bir sanat dalı
konservatuar okuyabileceğimi öğrenmiştim
çok heyecanlandım 2 yıl ben hedefimi
değiştirdim öğretmen olmayacağım sanatçı
olacağım dedim ve Konservatuarı
hazırlanmaya karar verdim
ikinci yılında
Anadolu Üniversitesi ve Konya Selçuk
Üniversitesi'nde Sınavlara girdim
kazanamadım çok heyecanlanıyordum bu
heyecanı strese dönüşüyordu yıl boyu
çalıştıklarımı ne yazık bir sahnede
Komisyonu gösterebiliyor
bunda çok zorlanıyordu Komisyonu ikna
etmek ne yazık ki imkansız hale gelmişti
3 yıl
bu stresten kurtulmak için bir yol
bulmam gerekiyordu
daha çok sınava girebilirim daha çok
sınırlı deneyimleyerek bir sonuca
kendime ulaştırabilirim diye düşündüm
önce Balıkesir'de sınava girdim birinci
aşamada elendim
oradan
Konya'ya geçtim birinci aşamayı geçtim
ikinci aşamada eğlendim
sonra Bursa birinci aşama geçtim ikinci
aşama geçtim 3 aşama hüsran yine
kazanamadım
sonra İzmir'e gittim
İzmir'de birinci aşamayı geçtim ikinci
aşamada yedeklere kaldım
ve son sınavım Anadolu Üniversitesi
Devlet Konservatuvarı sahnesi
Bursa'ya yakınlığından ve Eğitmen
kadrosunun iyi olduğunu düşündüğünden
hedefimdi burası
Bir yıl boyunca sınavlara odaklı yaşadım
spor yaptım kendime baktım Her gün daha
çok çalıştım
ve bir neticeye vardım Okulu kazanmıştım
Komisyonu sonunda ikna edebilmiştim
işlenebilir bir yeteneğim olduğunu
mükemmel 5 yıl yaşadım
üniversite hayatım konservatuar hayatım
çok keyifliydi müziği öğreniyordum
birbirinden kıymetli müzisyenlerle
Öğretmenlerle sanatçılarla çalışma
tanışma imkanı fırsatım oldu bir sürü
Turna yaptık bir sürü konser yaptık
öğrenci projeleri yaptık
5 yılımı tamamladığımda gelecek vadeden
Öğrencilerden bir tanesiydim
Fakat o sınavların operalarda devlet
operalarında sınavların açılmayacağı ile
ilgili bir bilgi dolaşıyordu
Bununla birlikte bir iş teklifi aldım
Eskişehir'de 2 yıllık Ticaretle uğraştım
okul bittikten sonra bu dönemin içindeki
planın dersler alarak kendimi
geliştirmekti yarışmalara katılmak ve
bireysel olarak bir Opera kariyeri
yapmakta fakat öyle olmadı Çünkü ticaret
hayatı
çok yoğundu hiç zaman ayıramadım ve
sanattan uzak kaldım 2 yıl uzak kaldım
ve hayat tam bu zamana kadar gelmişti
hayatımdaki en büyük eksik sana attı
opera sanatıydı
ve güzel haber
Ankara Devlet Opera balesi'nde bir sınav
açılıyor bir dinleti yapılacak her ses
grubundan
dinleti açılacak şöyle düşünüyorum 6 ses
grubu var orada 3'er kişi hastalar 18
kişi ya birer kişi alsınlar 6 kişi çok
fazla Çünkü çok az insan oluyor
Çok heyecanlıydım hemen gittim
şirketteki arkadaşlarımla toplantıda
bunu paylaştım bu sınava gireceğimi ve
olumlu bir sonuç elde edersem bir yol
var bununda olduğumuzu kendilerine
söyledim kabul ettiler desteklediler
fakat iki yıllık hiç Opera ile ilgili
bir şey çalışmamıştım o dönemde
yaptığımız mekanlardan bir tanesinde bir
tadilat yapılıyordu bir inşaat süreci
vardı benim de görevim o inşaatın başını
beklemekte her şey doğru işlesin diye
elime notalarımı aldım sınava bir ay
vardı ben bunu nasıl söylüyordum nasıl
yapıyordum kendimi hatırlamaya çalıştım
benden önce kuruma gelen benden sonra
mecbur olup kuruma gelen arkadaşlarım
çok defa beni bana hatırlatmak için
benimle sohbet ettiler Beni bana
hatırlatmak için beni bana ikna
edebilmek için
benimle çok defa sohbetler ettiler
onların hepsine minnettarım
sınav günü gelip çattığında bir kişinin
alınacağını öğrenmiştik
O bir kişi
ben olurum dedim
Bu sadece bir hisdi bunun
ukalalık olarak duyulmasını
duyulmasından Gerçekten çok üzülüyorum
sadece bir histen bahsediyorum O bir
kişi ben olacağımı O halde ve kazandım
Bu yıl Ankara Devlet Opera Vadisi 9
sezonu mu tamamladım ve opera kariyerimi
ikiye ayırıyorum iki ayrı bölüme ilk 5
yıl ve ikinci dört yıl ilk beş yıl
sadece sözleri ezberlemekte Opera
sanatından biraz uzakta sadece verilen
işi yapmaya çalışmakla geçen bir süreçti
sonra bir şeyler fark etmeye başladım
Sonra başka şeyler yaşamaya başladım
müzik başladığında etrafında Yeni Bir
Dünya oluşmaya başladığını hissetmeye
başladım başka şeyler görüyordum benden
çıkmaya başlamıştım oynadığım karakteri
hissetmeye başlamıştım
ve gerçek tutkumu
bu hayatındaki gerçek tutkumu bulduğuma
inanmaya başlamıştım
Çok emek harcadım üzerine çok çalıştım
yapabildiğimin en iyisini yapmaya
çalıştım
geçtiğimiz yıl geçtiğimiz sanat
sezonunda 5 gram Opera eserinde başrol
söyledim başrolü oynadım ve benim için
çok önemliydi bu
çok mutlu geçirdiğim dönemlerde
geçtiğimiz yaz
hayatında bir yol ayrımı yaşadım
cehennem gibi günlerden geçtim közlerin
üzerinde yürüdüğümü hissettim
yanıyordum resmen
insanın
önce Özde sonra Sözde sonra da
közde insan olabileceğini öğrenmiştim
iki büyük operasyonunda Premier yaptım
ve premier'in akşamında
yalnız hayatında
kendimle baş başaydın hiç kutlayamadım
bundan bir yıl önce tam 135 kiloydum
yaşadığım bu yol ayrımı biraz iştahımı
azalttı kilo vermeye başladım
sağlıksızlanmaya başladım
bir şeyler mi oluyordu hayatta
kötü hissettiren şeyler oluyordu Ama
güzel şeyler de vardı
ama hepsi müthiş deneyimlerde
bir sürü kırılma noktaları yaşadım
hayatım boyunca
bulunduğumuz yerde
başımıza gelen şeyler geçmişimizde ya da
şimdi de canımızı sıkıyor Olabilir bizim
mutsuz ediyor olabilir
fakat başka bir yerden baktığımızda
başka bir pencereden baktığımızda O
durum bizim için yaşanıyordu çok büyük
olasılıkla
başımıza gelen kötü şeyler
sonradan aslında ne kadar iyi şeylermiş
diyebiliyoruz
iyi ya da kötü çok şey yaşandı bundan
sonra da yaşanmaya elbet devam edecek
hepimize
hepimiz için bir dileğim var başımıza
gelecek iyi kötü her şeyi aynı sevgiyle
kucaklayabilelim isterim
Mevlana'nın dediği gibi
Gül düşünüp Gür İstanbul olalım dilerim
bu anı
bu an
benim
hayatımın kırılma noktalarından
yalnızca bir tanesi
[Alkış]